um I just saw that real great will Rex
Spielberg's movie that old movie like
from right yeah yeah yeah he's first
that was so brilliant yeah I just saw it
again have you ever seen it it's so
amazing it's like it's just about a guy
on the road and some other freaks that
you never see in a truck wanting to kill
him for no good reason but it's so
brilliant and and I thought you know the
questions you were saying asking me it's
like would a young filmmaker today have
the courage to to do a movie that's that
untrained II you know it was um trendy
then but back then there wasn't anything
else to compel young filmmakers to go oh
I gotta do the trendy thing now
Spielberg would still because he's like
from outer space or something he's just
so you know of his own making but how
many young filmmakers would have that
courage to resist the temptation to
follow the trend and that's the day you
know I would dangerous like hardly a
danger but it's I would say to any young
artist you know as seductive as it is to
imitate you you will become very
ordinary then well speaking of which you
talked about in the video that your
father traveled all over the world for
his job and as a result you were brought
in to just different countries cultures
everything what would you say to an
artist who may be stayed in the same
town growing up their parents are from
that town and it's fine but maybe they
weren't exposed to different ideas and
people what would you tell them to
enrich their creativity well actually no
you can see that from two sides because
I see I've met some friends you know who
never went anywhere but just being very
isolated day
became so sensitive to those a moment to
the environment that they were trying to
find the day we became great artist just
by the delimit limitations the focus o
their environment and in a way you know
I was very dispersed you know I never
really could cultivate long-term
relationships of anyone I was always
like jumping around from school to
school I always felt you know like an
outsider which sort of made me afraid to
deal with people became very often sort
of like an observer who just see things
from the outside even from the surface
at times so there's two sides to looking
at it on one hand in I felt like the
world was one were all one in a world
United I can see the very complexity of
things but on the other hand I felt very
often I misstated intimate deepness of
being in the moment you know so I think
there is but it's a balance you know and
but in a way now that because we're so
connected to the Internet in a way we
are global we're everywhere anywhere
anyway so it's almost not necessary to
go everywhere anymore because we're
reaching everyone and were communicating
with the whole world constantly so our
global citizens now just to the internet
you know right well I had interviewed a
lady Carol Francis who wasn't she's an
activist and a teacher and a filmmaker
and she loves the john sayles quote
which I'm butchering here but it's
something like filmmakers need to go out
and get a life so speak and then go and
make their movie so they go to film
school they're young they're there
they're in school there around people
their own age but then they go when they
try to make a movie about things that
maybe they haven't experienced yet yah
that's two I think that's the path of a
lot of great writers you know like you
look at a lot of famous writers they had
to slave away like you know and having
whatever go to war you know is really
like struggling to do it is you know in
fact to your question I mean Hemingway
he had an external life and he
he spoke of it that was his voice you
know and back to Brewster Kafka they
didn't need an external world and you
know plenty of artists their brain and
and their sensitivity their their
observance that's where their art is and
others need a broader brushstroke you
know and you know the Kerouac thing they
need the big Road you know others need
you know I need the the smaller journey
and but it's bigger emotionally you know
and it's to the sales quote I mean I i
understand it I mean you know when I
speak in a duel I mean Stephen you know
Spielberg was what like 22 23 you know
there are geniuses that come around that
have a lot to say early you know and
then there's a lot of people that want
to be artists that have nothing to say
early you know and then there's others
that you know Blum later it comes in
every shape I mean there's not as many
geniuses but and there's a whole bunch
of people that went to the right schools
have the right friends and say nothing
but the thing or the project or the
painting or the concert gets presented
but the the the lasting ones I mean you
know it's just amazing to see this movie
dual after I don't know 40 years it is
it's like there's not a beat that feels
old-fashioned you know because it's it's
done with such pure intention all
through it it's not based on well you
know like a lot of times I'll have read
a strip that an older person will write
you know about a young person okay and
I'll get it to do a rewrite or a friend
will ask me to read it you know and you
know they're writing about young 20 year
olds or high school and the first
mistake they all make is they just jam
it full full full with like tech and
blog and you know all this crap and I'm
like who cares like it's not going to be
there are four minutes and that is not
what a character is any more than you
know when we were growing up we weren't
about stereos I mean stereos are part of
our life but it's it's you gotta write
you know people have an emotional core
and it just that doesn't change
according to trends and that's why I
think this is you know our film is such
a beautiful and powerful film when
because it doesn't do that it's such a
simple pure little story of emotion you
know that it just it just bursts through
all that you know I mean sure we will
have some club scenes you know the girl
is gonna be trendy she say you know has
a cold safe head and whatever there's a
lot of trendiness in it but the essence
of it the core of its background yeah
its background her environment you know
nine ten to shoot in a very you know
flesh away and very gradient use all the
toys and gimmicks in analytical stuff
that we as filmmakers get to use these
days but the essence of it is just the
purity of the emotion you know they the
truth
you